Getting started to knit quickly is
a snap using Garment Designer.
How many times have you wanted to make a quick
sweater for an upcoming baby shower?
You wanted something quick and easy and you wanted to
take time to embellish the garment and not spend
a whole lot of time in front of the
compute. With Garment Designer
you can do this in just a few steps.
We're going to create this cardigan simple
baby cardigan in less than 10 steps.
Let's get started.
When you start a new pattern, the first thing you'll
notice is that there's a default garment on the
screen. We will use this as
our starting point.
Also, you'll see lots of lines. The green lines represent
the sloper which actually represents the
body and the black line
is the actual pattern.
So we are showing that we have some breathing room, some
ease in this garment. To make things simpler.
Let's go ahead and turn the sloper
off we'll click >display and >show pattern.
And that makes things a whole
lot easier to see.
Now we're going to be designing
a cardigan.
Let's set up our pieces
>display and >pieces.
Our garment pieces are front.
We both need both a right and a left, but they're not
going to be joined because it's a cardigan, they
will be independent.
We need a right and a left back,
but we want those joined.
We want one single back.
Our Sleeve has a front and a back
but we also want it joined.
There's no seam down that sleeve.
We're only going to work with one sleeve.
We don't need both of them on the screen.
Click.
OK and there we go.
Looks like we're getting close here.
Now before we forget let's enter our gauge.
We'll go to >options >units and gauge.
We've got some choices here.
I'm going to use stitches
and rows per inch.
Five and seven and click, OK.
The next thing we need to set up on
our pattern is a size.
We're going to be making a child sweater.
I don't want to do an infant's let's
make it a toddler sweater.
So that baby has something to grow
into. We can change the size here.
We'll make it a 2 toddlers.
And one thing I do notice is that this is
a set in sleeve now for baby sweaters.
I don't need to be bothered.
This is supposed to be quick and easy.
Let's make this just a straight
drop shoulder sleeve.
Again, very little shaping
quick and easy.
Another thing that I notice is there is a
sloped shoulder. For children's clothing
you really don't need to
slope that shoulder.
It's just a little more shaping
while you're knitting. Again
we want this thing to be fast. Change it from
sloped to straight and there we are.
We've got the basics of our sweater.
Believe it or not.
We're ready to start knitting.
I'd like to save this garment we'll >file and >save
as and we'll call it BABY and click on Save.
The next thing we want to do is see the
pattern. Where are my instructions?
I've got some nice pretty pictures on the screen.
will click >generate >shaping instructions and
voila.
There's our shaping instructions.
Click >file and >print these will print out for you. Take
them over to your knitting machine and you are
ready to go. Very few steps, a couple of
minutes and you're ready to go.
Now
If you're not used to the shaping instructions in
Garment Designer they're little bit different, but
the first time you use them you will fall in love with
them. You follow the instructions from the bottom
up.
So this is our right front.
We're going to cast on 31 stitches.
We're going to knit to
row 81. And it row 81
we're going to start shaping
our neckline.
We're going to take off 2 stitches which
will leave us 29. The next row
we're going to be taking off 2 stitches
on the right hand side.
Take us down to 27 all the way up to Row
90 where our last shaping takes place.
Row 95 we're all done and
will bind off 21.
So the next time you want a really quick sweater. Turn
to Garment Designer and you'll be knitting in no
time.